girl I know you got a lot going on so I
would imagine it's an obsession with
dogs that it's brought you out here
today Oh 100% I mean I'm a huge dog
lover I have my little rescue dog
maverick so I love spending so much time
with him and I'm just really excited to
be here and watch this movie which is
just highlighting all these incredible
dogs who are doing such amazing work and
I'm just so excited to see it you're
working with pedigree to write to kind
of celebrate these dogs
yeah partnering with pedigree we have a
lot of really exciting things coming up
and it's just such a incredible brand
that just does such great work for
rescue dogs and just getting the word
out about how important animal rescue is
so that's right right up my alley
I asked about another animal we're
obsessed with the Lambs like what have
you learned about raising these adorable
lambs that you guys are so cute with
that thank you so much I mean I I still
have a lot to learn when it comes to the
Lambs I feel much more knowledgeable
about dogs that's much more my lane and
just you know talking about animal
rescue and and just all that is much
more something that I'm aware of
confidently I want to learn more about
the lamb it's one thing you've learned
about raising lamb I mean I already knew
they were adorable but I just like
getting to hold them is just an
incredible experience and it's seeing
them interact with their moms but much
like any animal I mean dogs are the same
way just being able to see you know them
come into the world and be in such a
happy and great environment is just
really special
well you and Chris seems so happy
together I mean what is it about this
time of your life that has you glowing
because I you're like glowing today and
the way that you guys talk about each
other and I'm at an event around dogs if
you're not be glow around so many dogs
doing such great work so I mean I'm very
happy in all areas of my life and I feel
really blessed and really lucky so are
you guys managing all the time because I
saw you doing the house thing and
everything - yeah I mean we're managing
it we're very very good with managing
our time so
yes it's working out really well is he
going to be very involved in wedding
planning yeah I mean I I feel like we're
all really involved in wedding planning
I think that you know for me my family's
very involved I'm very involved he's
very involved so it's a great
combination of everything and just
really exciting and fun times and yes
and will you guys be adopting more dog I
mean on my overall goal is gonna rescue
every animal so it's gonna be it's a
goal in general so hopefully yes
[Music]
[Applause]